what's that part the sad part about all
this is the girl I mean she's never
gonna be able to do stand up so it's not
very funny good Lord that's where we are
today huh Colleen do you got one
after that do your Zinger dude look at
this camera right here
[Laughter]
we're on her side we are all on her side
[Music]
all right so this is in Erie
Pennsylvania there's these three college
students that are at a bar they're
hanging out at the top of these stairs
right I don't know somebody left a
wheelchair at the top of the stairs so
these three guys start kind of [__]
with it just like we're messing with it
and um
randomly one of the dudes decides to
just wash it down the stairs by itself
Yeah by itself this is just random
wheelchair turns out that wheelchair was
owned by a like Disabled Student that
was also there that needed to be carried
downstairs to go to the bathroom
so it's like just sitting at the top of
the stairs though yeah God that's so
tempting I know intrusive thoughts
what is it doing there this is a test
isn't it check if the brakes the brakes
aren't even on
before I tell you the rest of this I'm
just gonna play the video uh and then
I'll tell you the rest of this because
dude wheelchairs are heavy they're big
pieces of metal so here's the bar these
are the three dudes the way they're
standing around and it's exactly how I
pictured it it's like it's like four
monkeys discovered a hammer and of
course all their hats are backwards
that's dead on what is yeah look at this
so here they are chilling it's much more
narrow than I pictured messing around
they're just like joking with it dude
there's a whole party going on yo send
it these guys
that's what I where I would be
I wanted it to go all the way down I
wanted it to go dude yeah that was very
anti-climactic needed to put some weight
and they just walked away
the [__] cushion is all over wait so
what's that
was there like uh someone that was like
on crutches or what like how the [__]
did he get up out of his wheelchair
there's a Disabled Student that owns it
that had to be helped down by other
people so go to the restroom the
bathroom's at the bottom of the stairs
is it the kid from Rubble in the Bronx
oh so they parked it there yeah yeah
yeah yeah so they leave it stupid
because you know the secrets yeah the
cushion fell so I thought of the kid but
Danny from the boss there's diamonds in
it my boy like you better check the
[__] bags
wish my legs were like other kids and
why would you make him say that yes
[__] dumbass writer that's a great
movie
so what happened is uh you're gonna love
this by the way so I already love this
so the chair was damaged sadly
um yeah the girl comes back to find that
somebody was like cruel enough to Just
Launch it down there
um
drunk guys discover tools the kid the
kid who launched it down he turns out to
be this this dude named Carson Brier
who's a college hockey player at
Mercyhurst and uh ends up getting
suspended along with the other two dudes
but it also turns out that Carson's dad
is Daniel Breer who's the um the
Philadelphia Flyers interim general
manager
interesting so destroys life fire him
from everything yeah set him on fire
yeah yeah where's his mom work she
should be fired too she should be
executed actually I mean so the dad's
issuing like an apology that he's gonna
make sure to like get to the bottom of
his what he says is like a bad judgment
whatever and like of course everybody's
gonna get to the bottom of the stairs
we're gonna get to the
Southern money has been raised for the
girl to like replace her chair yeah
because those are expensive wheelchairs
are actually expensive yeah
I used to sell them they are if The
Pride chair would Fine By the way he
would have survived that fall should
have got a prize wait so people were
fundraising the guy who pushed it down
the stairs isn't gonna pay for it yeah I
that should be that's a good I think
that's even right hook me up with some
new [__] does the chair doesn't work
anymore the chair works I mean the chair
works the the wheels don't but it's all
[__] probably the wheel's all bent
the wheels are square damage to the
point where it doesn't it doesn't work
correctly it might work but it doesn't
work as it did they got a cheap one on
Amazon I think there should be two
things all right he has to pay for it he
has to work to pay for it his dad can't
pay for it and the second thing is
um he has to be 300 kicked down the
stairs there it is yeah Spartan kicked
this is Sparta boom and he has to be
kicked and he rolls down he mean I mean
he's a that that kid's a hockey player
at his college he's suspended for the
team oh what that sucks but I think he's
allowed to get back on the team team if
he's if he plays goalie and he has to
catch the puck by his dick
that's that's tough that's a really
tough one then yeah he just has to stand
there while they [__] use him as
target practice I thought you could say
he has to use the broken wheelchair
during the game dude take him to the
steps of the Philadelphia Museum where
Rocky was running and [__] put him in
the wheelchair
that's punishment
what's the sad part the sad part about
all this is the girl I mean she's never
gonna be able to do stand-up so it's not
very funny good Lord that's where we are
today huh Colleen do you got one
after that do your Zinger dude look at
this camera right here
we're on her side we are all on her side
well look we stand up
I think it's kind of harmless right you
look at those boys you're like dude
they're just being [__] boys they're
being a bunch of idiots he should
definitely pay for that [__] yeah he
should definitely pay pay for the
property that he damaged I don't think I
mean I may have done some [__] like this
back in the day but I don't think I've
ever done to a wheelchair or like just
like an AIDS victim Maybe
before I knew the diagnosis maybe a
blind person or something the most I've
done is the most I've done is what I
always used to do at school is I used to
do that to people's rolling backpacks I
thought that was hilarious you chucked
it down yeah
nobody was that much of a dork at your
school no they pulled a rolling no a
rolling bag you didn't go to school with
dorks we all did if you did that it was
like Velociraptors come out of the corn
fields you can smell it yeah
because guys like stepping on it yep
while they're rolling because when
you're doing the whole rolly bag it's
like that right so then you come up
behind them and you [__] stomp on it
and it their hand gets released I used
to love doing that I remember like it
was at it was in high school I think it
was like a a sophomore and this this
little Indian kid he was like one of the
very few Indian kids at our school he
had a rolling backpack and he was
walking out and these like chicks were
like like uh look at this dumbass
rolling backpack like they were saying
that I don't know why it seemed kind of
weird but she was like talking [__]
about I was like oh why you got a
rolling backpack and he's like I have
scoliosis and then walked away and then
they were all like I just mowed it dude
so you guys are making fun of those
people okay because these kids might
have scolios scoliosis
have you got scoliosis on this side
maybe get a backpack and get it
corrected on this side you know what I
mean because kids were getting scoliosis
from having heavy you know backpacks
because they wanted to be cool yeah and
it's just they were like wear the
backpack correctly guys yeah but then
somehow everyone was like nah you know
if I if I wear it like this then that
means I'm gay so then they thought that
their sexuality was very you know that's
what people told me when I when I was a
freshman they were like uh never run to
class if you're late because you'll be
gay and I was like you're gay if you run
to class okay if you run can I just
remember the Bell would ring and I'm
like oh [__] and I would just have to
still walk oh my God
you're internally like stressed but
you're still gotta walk because I was
like new there and everybody knew each
other they're not cool if you run to
class yeah you look like an idiot but
but if some of the kids saw you walking
and the bell rang and there they saw you
like late and you were just cruising
they'd be like yo that dude is cool as
that or or two guys who are running look
at each other and like oh
you
[Laughter]
that's how you'd identify it that's how
you try to find someone you're purposely
late
that's the 90s for you man yeah
how I met your father I think I've ever
messed with any disabled person's
equipment yeah actually the more I think
about it that's [__] up bro that's
super fun tough
it took me five minutes but we've come
around the corner
she probably had it coming no no no
I mean whether she was mean what's
Devil's Advocate no there's no Devil's
Advocate it's just like it's such it's
one of those things where it's like I
cannot believe that these guys are so
[__] stupid but it is just so stupid
it's like they're like let's go [__]
with the disabled girls it's not like
she was in it yeah we don't know we
don't know that like if they cut the
brakes off or something that's [__] up
they were like they threw it down and
then put it back or no why are you
laughing can you cut the brakes of the
right hold
[Laughter]
on
it's just that little flap yeah it's a
little fluffy a doctor's wheel of the
person along and then they're like oh no
oh no no no no
the break the brakes are up yeah it
won't break it's picking up a speed dude
[Laughter]
you tell me that they're in a hilly area
I agree this as well or what I mean is
you're someone you're sitting in a
wheelchair you think the brakes work
yeah so when you want your chair to be
stable you lock it down and then that's
when you try to get it
next thing you know you're 40 miles away
in a cornfield
you're just rolling down Runyan Canyon
yeah bro especially when you think the
brakes aren't working and then you do
something right don't cut the brakes
that would be fun though or you like say
that if they cut a hole on the bottom of
the chair and they made it look like it
was totally fine and then as soon as
that person sat and they fall through
that's [__] up that's [__] up but if
they don't have use with their legs they
won't feel it so it's not that [__] up
just just being Devil's eggs again a
little bit it won't hurt I think how
you're here man we can do Devil's
Advocates I think you balance out the
room yeah yeah kind of look at the
positives yeah we gotta look at all
angles if we're going to talk about a
subject but don't cut the brakes that is
okay have you ever cut a hole in
someone's chair no that's such a big
budget prank
that's a her
pranks dude
oh I did that to you why would you I cut
a hole in a giant ottoman it was an
ottoman and they cut a hole in it I had
to cut it for a shoot so like but then I
covered it with a blanket when she came
over okay Kristen sit on the ottoman I'm
like okay disappeared and she fell
through the couch Kristin you need to
sit down at all he took a picture of me
sitting in the Ottoman and you know how
Ryan puts pictures of pictures we have
this and oh man Photoshopped it where
there's like old guy sitting in a hot
tub and it looks just like me
that one's taken yeah it was like a time
she tried to like run across it and
forgot the hole was still there and
she's super tumbled yeah oh my gosh but
yeah that's a great picture so yeah I
did do that so cutting holes is a prank
it's a thing cutting holes in seats or
have you seen the ones where people put
the um
like like a airbag and they put it
that's dangerous to your spine dude
those are crazy have you seen those
videos no they always do it like a
mechanic shop and they'll put like a guy
would be sitting on break and they'll
put an airbag under his cushion so as
soon as he sits he flies it goes off and
he flies up and he falls on the ground
my favorite shoes I like the ones where
like the guys he's about to sit down and
the guy behind him takes a chair away
and he's like oh whoopsie it hits us
right afterwards classic Hometown true
Classics that's an AFV they've been
doing that [__] for centuries we used to
do well I used to do this thing where
you would take two Staples you know like
little Staples you ever twist them no so
you take two Staples and you twist them
like the bread packets where you like
twist the little twisty thing yeah you
twist them so it looks like a jack like
when you're playing Jacks you just put
them all over a chair and they go
straight into people's asses when they
sit classic wow
we just come but I used to call the butt
trap I keep making it looked like more
people did it but it was just you dude
yeah there's a thing there's a there's a
common saying it's no it's I just made
up the word yeah so I've done a lot of
messed up things I don't I don't think
this is on the other side that's [__]
up yeah the border for me that's very
[__] up yeah I would never do anything
like this but what do you what do you
think do you think the dad needs to take
any of this Flack that should go down on
a wheelchair with them
Kanye and Kim
and Kim he raised them so he should go
to jail too with the sun
that's too harsh get rid of the whole
family
erase their bloodline you shouldn't be
able to be in society yeah ship them
away Guantanamo get him out of here
and also he's the interim general
manager he's not gonna be there for long
you know what I mean oh that does suck I
feel like he'll lose his job pretty
right really
thank you
[Music]